well if you've got kids chances are at
least one of them is into video games
now cyber criminals are trying to use
your kids gaming habits to get into your
bank account
they prey on that innocence and that
naivete that our kids have the newest
trick from cyber thieves steal gamer's
identities tap bank accounts and run up
mom and dad's credit cards
[Music]
trying to get them to get information
from parents you know credit card
numbers there's so many different ways
that these online predators
and the scammers try to target our
children scams offer kids things they
value free access to online games prizes
are special features young people can be
easy marks kids are being exposed to
technology at much younger ages than you
or i ever were metro sergeant allen
larson says parents have to make sure
kids know they should be leery find a
news article or a blog or something else
where it talks about how a kid was
specifically scammed and then how that
hurt them and then relay those stories
to them scammers create fake versions of
popular games use phishing scams to get
account details send fraudulent emails
or fake qr codes to grab a password they
want to get into the kids info to get
out with mom and dad's credit card
when we allow our kids unfettered access
to the internet on a tablet or a phone
or a computer in their rooms without us
having any kind of eyes on it or being
in close proximity we have absolutely
zero clue what can parents do
white listing websites use strong
passwords never share credit card info
use two-factor authentication set
filters to implement parental controls
including a feature where you type in
your apple id they actually can't even
download anything in the app store or
anything else without getting your
permission and if there is one tip to
take from this cyber scam problem one
thing to watch for if you're a parent is
don't enable face id for app purchases
and things like that for your younger
children and just like we've all heard
for generations your kids need to hear
the good ol if it sounds too good to be
true it probably is they're a lot more
trusting than maybe we were and a lot
more naive than we were when we were
kids